Hello and welcome to your second drink of the surplus.
This is the episode where Oscar explains to Michael that he has to spend the office surplus,
and it kicks off this big debate over what the bullpen wants to spend it on.
Chairs are a new copier.
This is also when Dwight takes Angela and Andy to Shrewd Farms.
It was a very fun episode of the Office, one of my favorite to shoot, and also one of my favorite episodes of Office Ladies.
So listen, lady, I was revisiting this one.
and I did this deep dive on butter sculptures at the Iowa State Fair because when Angela is talking about planning her wedding,
she says she wants a cat butter sculpture.
I remember when we did our stories, you sent me all of these pictures you found of butter sculptures.
Yes.
Well, guess what?
I have an update.
Okay.
A butter sculpture update.
I want everyone to know that the Iowa State Fair will be going on this year from August 13th to 23rd.
and yes, there will be a butter cow per usual.
And it will be sculpted by Sarah Pratt,
who has been making the butter cow since 2006.
Her two daughters, Hannah and Grace, are now her apprentices.
And listen, I'm telling you, I got so interested in these sculptures again
that I ended up watching some videos of Sarah and her daughters from last year's fair.
And they use their hands a lot to do the sculpting.
I don't know what I was expecting. Tools, I don't know. I totally envision it as like them using their hands, like almost like a clay, like making pottery. That is what it was like. I envisioned it like, I don't know, like an old timey like chisel and hammer. But no, they do. They use their hands to mold it. And then it cools into the shape that they're going for. It's really fascinating. I want to watch it. And one day, I need to see these butter sculptures in real life. Can we please do this?
this lady, I mean it, I mean it.
My bags are packed.
Okay.
I mean, I am in.
I love butter.
I know you do.
And I love things sculpted out of other things, I guess.
This is a good match for us.
Mm-hmm.
Well, lady, this is also the episode where we finally gave you your first work birthday.
Yeah.
But your cake was late.
It was a whole thing.
You can listen to it in the episode.
but when we put a call out to our listeners to tell us their favorite moment from the surplus,
we got this letter from Jordan G in Orlando and Angela I had to share.
Jordan said,
Hi, ladies, this is more of a response to your episode of the podcast and less about the show itself.
I'm currently listening to the surplus episode for the first time where Angela gets her first work
birthday party.
I just want to say how touching that moment was when Angela was surprised with her cake,
It literally made me tear up.
One of my favorite things about the podcast is being able to have a look into the friendship
between you two.
It is so honest and special, and your obvious connection and love for one another is truly
something so amazing to get to witness.
You make me laugh, cry, and everything in between.
I feel like I'm right there with you.
I'm sure you've heard it a million times, so what's one time more?
Thank you for creating something so special for everyone.
many blessings to both you and your family. Love always, Jordan. Well, Jordan, gosh, that just,
you know what, just completely made my day. Thank you so much. I know. I thought that was so sweet.
And she also had a P.S. I guess I met Jordan in Arizona. At the University of Arizona in 2018,
I had done a book signing for the actor's life. She said, I was literally one of the last people in line
and you still took time to talk with me and sign my book. And as an actor who now,
gets paid full time to perform. Way to go, Jordan. Yes. It was huge encouraging me through those
tough times we all face. Ah, Jordan, yay. Congratulations. Yeah. And thank you for writing in.
Thank you so much, Jordan. Well, I have a letter here from Hannah B in Canada who says,
first off, love you ladies so much. I rewatched the surplus recently and love the scene where Michael
calls in Hank to make the final decision, especially the moment when Hank realized
the power he's been given.
Was it scripted that he would take the jelly beans?
And Michael responds very seriously
that he can take as many as he wants.
Stephen Hughes' energy in this scene is hilarious.
I mean, it is so fantastic.
Hannah, we mentioned in our breakdown
that this is our favorite as well.
Oh, yes.
So much.
It's so good.
And Hannah, I went to the script
and it was scripted that Hank
takes some jelly beans,
but that's all it said.
Steve improvised the line, take as many as you want, and Hugh improvised the thank you, thank you,
before his next scripted line that was, you know, it's nice and warm up here. And I actually think this
little bit that Hannah points out is such a great example of improv on the show, Ang, because we weren't
improvising whole scenes. We would have a scripted bit and then we'd do some little thing and then we'd go
back to scripted and we did it so seamlessly. Yeah, because we had really great writing when there were
these little moments where we could sort of add a little color, we knew right where to do them.
Do you know what I mean? It was just so organic. Yes. Oh, and lady, while I was poking around in the
script looking for the answer to this question, oh my gosh, I found not one, but two cold opens for
this episode. We did not talk about this in our breakdown. Ooh. And this episode does not have a
standalone cold open. We just get right into the plot. Oscar just enters Michael's office and tells
him about the surplus. But there were actually two standalone cold opens written for this
episode. I think we only ended up filming one of them. It got added back to the top of the Peacock
Superfan episode. It is a prank that Jim pulls on Dwight. Let's hear it.
What is this thing you just sent me?
Oh, it's really cool.
It's a picture of the most relaxing meadow you've ever seen.
Idiot.
I know what this is.
It's supposed to lull me into a sense of calm,
and then a ghoul pops up and scares me.
Why would I do that?
Dwight, of all people I know that you're unscarable.
Damn right, I am.
Oh, hello, relaxing meadow.
I'm so relaxed and calm looking at you right now.
Oh, no, a scary ghoul just popped up.
I'm so scared, I'm so scared.
Really? Is this the best you could...
Jim?
How are you?
Okay.
That is the best I can do.
He got him.
He got him, lady.
Yeah, so what he does, because you can't see it,
he is right over Dwight's shoulder in a scary mask,
and that is what ends up scaring Dwight.
So that is now at the top of this episode in The Superfan,
but they wrote another cold open for this episode
where Michael and Dwight discover that it's snowing outside.
And we all run outside and have a snow.
But there's not a lot of snow. So the snow is kind of like filled with pebbles. You know when you're like trying to make a snowman, but there's not enough. Yeah. Or snowball or whatever. So you get dirt and sticks and stuff. Yeah. Well, anyway, I bet they're glad they chose this one in the bullpen because then they didn't have to spend a bunch of money on fake snow just to have it get cut from the episode.
That's all I could think of when you shared that. I thought they were going to have to call snow business and get a bunch of fake snow. Yeah, but they do.
didn't. I don't think we shot it. Well, I love a cold open surprise. Well, I also want to talk about
this letter we got from Cassie L. and Milton, Florida. Cassie said, I'm currently watching the
superfan episodes, and there's a scene between Angela and Dwight that has been added back in where
we find out Angela is very passionate about the Mayflower. And it seems that Dwight knows this by his
reaction. So Cassie wants to know, how many times have they had deep conversations about the Mayflower?
This scene made me laugh out loud.
I went back and watched it three more times.
Yeah, it was really fun.
And it just, it's one of those scenes, lady, I loved that wasn't in the original, that just shows the history of a couple.
You know, there's all this assumed history that you carry around with you when you are in a relationship with someone and just a window into it is so delicious.
It's like when we got to see Michael and Jan's condo, you know?
I'm like, what?
They've been living this all this time.
But I thought it'd be fun to hear.
It's after the scene in the kitchen where they are getting the directions to Shrewd Farms,
Angela and Dwight sneak out to the alleyway next to the warehouse.
Let's listen.
I thought you were going to put a muzzle on that singing idiot.
He's not a bad singer.
He is pretty talented, I guess.
And he went to Cornell.
Yeah, well, I provide America with two of its most beloved staples, beads and paper.
His family is well connected in pockets of Connecticut.
And his ancestors came over on the ma'amination.
Oh, big whoop. Half my family came over on a U-boat and would have destroyed the Mayflower.
Listen to you. Destroyed the Mayflower?
Sorry. I can't believe I said that. Angela.
That's so fun. I so remember doing that scene. You know how some you hear and you're like,
I don't really remember that. I remember saying deep pockets of Connecticut.
It's so good. She's so impressed.
I also love that Dwight has to admit he is a good singer.
Yeah. Well, you know what?
What's crazy is that in the background of this scene, lady, there's a little bit of snow on the dumpster.
And you guys are acting like you're really cold.
So I kind of wonder, when did we shoot this?
Was this before or after they decided to bail on that snow cold open?
They were like, we don't know what the cold open is going to be for this episode yet.
So just throw some snow out there so it matches, just in case.
Just in case.
Okay, everyone, well, thanks so much for sending in your letters about your favorite moments.
We love them.
you can submit your favorites at our website,
OfficeLadies.com.
And now it's time for your second drink of the surplus.
I'm Jenna Fisher.
And I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on The Office together.
And we're best friends.
And now we're doing the Ultimate Office
Rewatch podcast just for you.
Each week we will break down an episode of The Office
and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories
that only two people who were there can tell you.
We're the Office Ladies.
Today is a very special day.
Yes.
It is the last day.
that Angela will be in her 40s.
It is, you guys.
I am 49, staring at 50.
By the time you guys hear this, I'll be 50.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
You'll be a hot 50 lady.
Ooh, hot 50.
I was asking you the other day, what does it feel like?
Like, what does 50 feel like as you're approaching this milestone birthday?
I think I've been in denial because I've just been busy with life and kids and whatnot.
But I'm realizing now it feels big.
You know what I mean?
Like, I realize I'm in a different survey group.
Like, they're like, Americans 18 to 35 surveyed.
Americans, 35 to 45 surveyed.
I'm like, oh, my God, I'm not in the survey anymore.
I'm in the like senior citizens surveyed 50 to 75.
You're going to get surveyed about all like aches and pains and things now, right?
You know what?
My grandmother lived till 100.
And I'll never forget when she was 96.
Her and I were hanging out. She was the best. Her name was Lena Mae. And I said, Grandmother, you're about to turn 97. How does it feel? And she said, well, you know, when I'm sitting down, I feel like I'm 23. It's when I stand up that I feel 97.
Oh, that's amazing. Isn't that amazing? And then she said, nothing's broken, but none of it really works.
So you guys, I'm very excited today because here I am at work, the week of my birthday,
and that means I'm getting a birthday cake, right?
For the first time ever at work?
Sam, do you have it?
Is it hiding?
I saw your Arby's bag.
Is it behind it?
Nope.
What?
Angela.
Jenna, you said you had something in your car.
Is this a ruse?
No.
What was in my car is my son's electric guitar.
that I accidentally brought today.
I thought it was code for cake.
I thought you were going to get cake this whole time.
No, I mean, I can bring you down to the car
and you're going to see a red electric guitar in my trunk.
When I got here, Lee texted me,
and I realized I picked him up from guitar last time,
and I never took it out of the trunk.
Oh, my God.
You guys...
Do you want a red electric guitar?
A week of strum, happy birthday on it.
No, I think this is perfect.
I think I need to finish my 40s,
never getting cake on my birthday.
But next year, I want a fucking car.
cake. Okay, I'm going to be 50. It's about fucking time. Someone gives me a fucking cake when I'm at work
for my fucking birthday. So 51, do you hear me? Do you hear me? I want a cake. And now I'm looking at
you. Oh, boy. And Cassie, I know you're in there somewhere in the Zoom. I'm 50. This is what
happens when you're 50. You're like, I'm fucking 50. Give me what I want. Okay.
I think we all feel really bad.
I would never want you to feel bad, ever.
Are you messing with me?
Lady, I swear it's an electric guitar.
I feel like now...
I mean, you guys, it was really funny.
She was like, I have to run to my car.
I know.
Sam, it's about the guitar.
And I'm like, this is code for cake.
They're messing with me.
Angela, we officially apologize that there is no cake here.
I am going to see you tomorrow on your actual birthday
to celebrate your actual birthday
where you will be getting a cake.
Yes.
Because I'll be dropping by Gelson's tomorrow tonight to get it.
Because by God, you're getting a cake.
Okay.
All right, done.
This week, we are talking about the surplus.
It is Season 5, Episode 10, written by Gene Stupnitsky and Lee Eisenberg and directed by Paul Feig.
Do you want to hear a fun little tidbit about the title?
Yes.
As you guys know, I am a digital hoarder.
and every once in a while it brings me a real nugget.
I found an email from Randy Cordray saying that we were tentatively going to be shooting this episode
in October of 2008, end of October.
And the title, the working title was, spend the surplus.
Oh!
Spin the surplus.
And then we just dropped the spend.
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
So as you watch this, know that we're filming end of October 2008.
I went on a website that tells you weather years past.
You guys, the high was 88 degrees.
In October.
And if you watch us shivering outside, know that that's a faky shiver.
Oh, I have some things to say about that when we get there.
Okay.
I'm going to hit you with a summary.
Do it.
Oscar informs Michael there is a $4,300 budget surplus that must be spent today or it gets returned and taken out of next year's budget.
The office is then divided on what to spend it on.
New chairs or a new copier.
This creates tension between Jim and Pam who are on opposing sides.
Pam is team chairs.
Jim is team copier.
Andy and Angela visit Shrewt Farms to discuss their wedding with Dwight.
Michael then learns of a third option for the surplus.
He can return it in exchange for a 15% bonus for himself.
What will he choose?
Well, he doesn't like to make anyone mad, but he also wants the money.
Yeah.
Fast fact number one, the character of Ryan does not appear in this episode.
Good catch.
Yeah. Remember last week he told Kelly he was going to go to Thailand?
Well, this marks his first episode on his vacation and he will be gone for 11 weeks because he was filming in glorious bastards, the Quentin Tarantino film.
This was such a big deal for BJ. We were so excited.
He was working with Brad Pitt.
I know.
We really hit him up for Brad Pitt stories and he had nothing.
He just said he was a nice guy.
We're like, come on, give us something.
I know.
And then he would drop and do like a one-arm push-up.
BJ, we get it.
You have to get in good shape.
We get it.
Mm-hmm.
Fast fact number two, our cinematographer for this episode, was Matt Sown.
Yeah.
So this actually happened back on business trip because remember, Randall Einhorn, our usual cinematographer, directed business trip.
So while he was directing Matt Sown, who was normally our B camera operator, stepped in as cinematographer.
But this started a stretch where Matt served as our A camera operator and cinematographer for three weeks while Randall was doing post-production on his episode of business trip.
And so these last three episodes, that's Matt Sown, y'all.
I love that.
Matt Sown was the best.
He is such a hiker.
Do you know that?
Yeah.
Didn't he and David Dunman used to hike a bunch?
They hike a bunch.
I saw him on a hike one time, and I was like sucking air so hard.
And he like strode past me with his kid in one of those backpack things.
Oh, yeah.
And I was like, shoot, he was really in good shape.
He and Randall both were in good shape.
I know.
But I mean, they need to be because they're lugging those cameras on their shoulders.
Although now Matt directs.
Yes.
Now he just hikes for pleasure.
Yeah.
Fast fact number three.
a very big portion of this episode takes place at Shrut Farms. And Angela, I know you will have a lot to
share about that. But to kick things off, you have a location breakdown from Randy Cordray.
I sure do. You guys, Randy Cordray is the best. Jenna has shared with you emails that he is sent to us.
I reached out to him because I had questions about Shroot Farms. We have shared over the years that there
were a few different locations for Shrewd Farms. And I just wanted to ask Randy, which location
it was, and I had a question about the barn. He responded to my email, Jenna, with so many details,
it was so wonderful, and photos. I'm going to share. Here we go. Are you ready for Randy Cordray's
location breakdown of Shrewd farms? Yes. These scenes were shot in Newhall at the Disney Ranch.
It was originally known as the Golden Oak Ranch. And Jenna, Randy gives us a deep dive
on the origin of the Golden Oak Ranch. Lay it on me. He did a
deep dive. This is what he said. It was land owned by the famous singing cowboy movie star, Gene Autry.
Gene Autry also owned the California Angels baseball team and the Los Angeles News Station, KTLA,
Channel 5, which was the first TV station on the West Coast. Randy also shared that the Walt Disney
Company purchased the property in 1959 and established a movie location on a still working horse
and cattle ranch, there's more. He shared that just beyond the boundary of the property to the south
in Placarita Canyon State Park is the site of the very first gold discovery in California. In 1842,
a cow hand named Francisco Lopez was sitting under an oak tree and pulled up some wild onions. He found
gold nuggets clinging to the roots. His discovery led to a mini gold rush, six years,
before the more famous discovery of gold at Sutter's Mill.
Wait, he pulled onions out of the ground and there was gold clinging to, like, the onion
or the root of the onion?
Yeah, gold nuggets clinging to the root of this onion, and it happened right there,
and that is why it's called the Golden Oak Ranch.
It should be called the Golden Onion Ranch.
He was sitting under an oak tree.
It should be called a Golden Oak Onion Ranch.
Golden Oak Onion Ranch.
Rolls off the tongue.
So there's the background on the origin of the Golden Oak Ranch, which then became the Disney Ranch.
So we spent a lot of time at this Disney Ranch filming this episode.
There's tons more scenes that didn't make it in.
We were there the whole week.
This was weird for me, Jenna, because I was the one not in the office.
And you were there.
Yes.
When we shot there, the facilities were just limited to a few buildings, a farmhouse, some barns, and stables.
right? Randy shared with us that in the corner of the ranch, there was a very run-down Western
Street that was really in disrepair, and it was. It looked like a set that had been forgotten about
because no one was making those spaghetti Westerns anymore. It probably had its heyday, but it was
really falling apart. But Randy shared that since then, Disney has invested a ton of money
and has completely modernized the grounds. He said I wouldn't even recognize it. There are six
state-of-the-art sound stages. There's also a fake residential street.
and a business district, and there's a full feature backlot movie location now.
None of that was there when we were there.
It was like a run-down old, like, Western set when we were there.
I've been there because I was there for the bed and breakfast.
Yeah.
When Jim and Pam go to, you know, stay at Shrewd farms.
And there was nothing.
It was really just these rickety farmhouses and barns that were basically falling apart.
Right.
And there was only a handful of them and then just sort of fields.
Yeah.
Well, now it's a full studio.
Wow.
I know.
I asked him a little bit about the barn we filmed in, and he said the very first scene you see of us walking into the barn, that stable was called the rag-wing barn.
And Randy negotiated a rate to include the horses and mules and the horse that you see in the stalls.
Oh.
And then the other barn, which was like the fancy barn where Dwight, you know, made it to look like a wedding ceremony.
Yes.
That barn was known as pee-wees because it was the former location.
used in Paul Rubin's Pee Wee's Playhouse.
Oh, wow.
So they all had names.
And the actual Shrewt farmhouse was an old farmhouse on the property known as Olivia's.
That's really cool.
I know.
And he sent me pictures of the mules that he took that day.
And he sent me like the map of the location, which it doesn't look anything like that anymore.
It's so wild.
It's completely different.
That's so cool.
Thank you, Randy Cordray.
I know.
He's the best.
He really came through.
I know.
Well, listen.
Should we take a break while I run to the store and buy you a cake and you go to the bathroom and we'll be back to break down this episode?
Are you going to go get me a guitar?
Yeah, I'm going to go get the guitar out of my car now.
All right, awesome.
I'm going to need about 20 minutes.
Okay.
We are back and Oscar is presenting Michael with the overall budget for the fiscal year.
And he is trying to explain that they have a surplus of $4,300.
Michael's not quite getting it.
he says, explain it to me like I'm eight years old.
Then he says, explain it to me like I'm five.
I know.
So Oscar does this great lemonade stand analogy.
Michael seems like he's getting it.
Ultimately, in the end, we're not sure he totally got it.
No.
But Oscar says, you need to spend this money today, and you should really spend it on a new copier.
Because we need it.
We desperately need it.
We had a fan question.
from Lauren K. When Oscar is explaining the surplus to Michael and Michael says, explain it to me like
I'm five, there's this great line when Oscar says, then next summer, and Michael says, I'll be six.
That made me laugh so hard. So hard. Lauren wanted to know, was that scripted or was it improvised?
It was scripted. That beat. Steve threw it away so perfectly. It was so cute.
It was so innocent.
I know.
Oh, Michael.
Well, he's very excited.
He knows it's something good, right?
He grasped at least that.
And he's going to announce to the whole bullpen.
Yes.
They've got a surplus.
And he thinks maybe we'll get a new copier.
And Pam's like, no, no, no.
Wait, wait, hold up.
We need new chairs.
Toby feels like they really need a good air quality inspection for some of the silent killers.
Here's Toby again.
He's worried about the radon gas.
He's worried about the asbestos.
This is the runner that the writers loved for Toby.
And this is the scene where we realize that Jim is not team chairs.
He wants a copier.
It really made me laugh hard when Creed goes,
The ball's on you, man.
Creed's delivery was so good.
And Jenna, there was a Pam talking head that would have gone here.
And it's about her chair.
and you delivered it from reception.
It's a talking head from reception.
In my chair.
Standing next to your chair.
Oh, what is it?
Sam, play it.
This is the chair that was here when I was hired.
It was crappy then, and it's even worse now.
To give myself a break, sometimes I go outside and sit on the ground.
Oh, yeah, I remember that now.
That's how bad that chair is.
I thought Pam made a really strong argument.
She made me want to be team chair,
because she was like, I make the copies.
I'm the one that has to deal with the copier.
That should tell you how bad these chairs are.
Well, and also, everyone would get a new chair, right?
So it really is something for everyone.
But the other thing I thought was just,
what about the copier in the annex?
There's another copier.
No one wants to walk to the annex.
It's icky back there.
Well, then they should swap them.
I know.
Maybe Kelly needs to make a lot of copies.
It feels like there's a simple solution to the copier problem that no one's realizing.
Well, Michael's going to digest all of their ideas and see what comes out the other end.
Coming up at 3 minutes, 56 seconds, is a scene, Jenna, that I didn't think I was going to get through.
I didn't think we would have any usable takes.
Last week, you talked about that clown painting on the wall in Jim's parents' house that you guys could not get through it.
You were laughing.
Yes.
This scene with Dwight giving directions to Andy and Angela, that was it for me.
Ed and I, we could not get through it.
Like truly, we could not stop laughing.
It's in the bloopers, and I think we got to hear it.
You know, lady, last week I looked at the bloopers to see if I could find any clown painting outtakes.
Yeah.
I couldn't find them, but I did see this.
It is so good.
Just, I feel like some of these directions to Shrewd farms are a little weird.
I mean, like, 156 paces from the light red mailbox make a left.
Walk until you hear the beehive and make a right.
If you are attacked by territorial crows.
I have, this is a really easy.
If you smell bear,
pee turned the other way.
I...
If you smell bear pee at any
point, abort, wait in your car
for further instructions. What's the problem
exactly?
The other thing that's so great about this blooper
is that you're hearing all those candy bag
alt directions. Yes, because
in the script, the only directions
were 156 paces
from the light red mailbox and then the one
about the bear. All the rest
are candy bag alts. So were they
just because in the clip you can see that Ed is reading, were they just handing him pieces of paper with like funny directions?
They literally did. They handed him a whole paper that were extra directions. And that's why he was like, I almost had it.
And if you guys watch the bloopers, you'll see that I'm sniffling. I am sniffling because it was so cold on set that day that my nose was running. And I had a tissue in my hand that I was hiding under the table. It was that cold.
That used to happen to me all the time my nose would run on set.
I know.
I had my sneezing from the allergies and the runny nose from the cold.
Well, I rewatched this scene and all I can see is me sniffling and trying not to laugh.
Well, you laughed a lot.
I did.
Well, Jenna, we had a fan question about this scene.
Allie Joe H wrote in and said, when Angela and Andy are talking to Dwight, Andy says something about a three-way and it looks like Dwight mouth something to Angela.
Do you remember what he said?
I can tell you in the script, Rain had this stage direction.
It says, Dwight rolls his eyes to Angela like,
check out the dummy.
And Angela doesn't give him anything.
So I think Rain was sort of mocking Andy in that moment,
like looking at me like, oh, this guy.
Coming up, we have a scene that was really, really fun for me.
It's the scene in the kitchen between Pam and Jim,
where Pam is kind of low-key, threatening Jim to be on her side.
Not low key. Full key? Is that an expression?
We had a fan question from Jessica Kay. She would very much like us to discuss Pam's Your on Dangerous Ground moment saying, quote, I was like, damn, Jenna.
Well, Jessica, we came up with this little moment while we rehearsed the scene. So this idea of Pam going over to gym and going in for a kiss but then pulling back, that was something that we,
did in rehearsal. It was not in the script and we just were so tickled. You know those moments when you're
rehearsing a scene or you're doing a scene and you come up with this idea that just opens it up in this new way?
It's so fun. And it's so fun to see everyone else realize it too because I have to imagine that when
Paul Fieg saw it. He was like, oh yes, you have to do that. Yeah. It was really, really cool. And then we knew
we shot this scene first. We were going to mirror it in the tag at the end.
with Jim. Oh, it's so good. And I love Jim's talking head afterward. He was like,
ugh, spooky. You guys were about to head out to Shrewp Farms. There was a deleted driving scene.
It was so good. There's actually two. I'll get to the other one. Wait, there's a scene of you and
Andy and Dwight driving in a car together? Two. Oh, they are bookends. One going there and then one
when we leave. Stop it. Yes. The one on the way there, Dwight and Angela get into a fight.
So Angela's driving.
That tracks for me.
Angela's driving and her car is filthy.
It's like covered in mud.
It's so funny.
Oh.
I know.
Is that because maybe she's been going out to Shrew Farms recently?
Yeah.
So she's driving.
Dwight's in the front and Andy's in the back poking his head through.
It's amazing.
For both scenes.
These scenes were so much fun to film.
On the way there, Angela and Dwight are arguing about centerpieces at the reception.
Angela wants a fish bowl with a fish in it.
Dwight's like, let's put a piranha in it and that will kill the fish and there'll be blood.
And she's like, I don't want blood on my wedding day.
And then he's like, well, I guess I have to reorder the cake.
Oh, no, that's horrible.
I know.
What is this cake?
And Andy's like, you too.
That is on the DVD.
The other one isn't on the DVD, but I'm going to share it later because it's when they're leaving shrewd farms.
When Dwight is giving Andy and Angela a tour of shrewd farms, they get into another discussion about, I guess,
On theme with blood, they're talking about the slaughter. Do they really have to slaughter the
entrees on the day of the wedding? Yeah. I mean, yeah. I know. And Andy gets Dwight to not do it the
day of the wedding. And then Andy's like, what's that smell? Oh my gosh, I'm so Southern. Did you hear that?
Smale. What's that smell? It's a vowel before an L. I can't do it. And Angela goes,
manure. Get rid of it. We had a lot of fan questions about the manure. Oh, yeah? Like a lot.
everybody wanted to know, was it real manure? No, it was not. It was made by Phil Shea. That was
Phil Shea's job that day, make faky manure, and he... How did he do it? He mixed mostly oatmeal,
a little bit of sand, and some food coloring. Well, it looks like manure. It does. Good job,
Phil Shea. Lee Eisenberg shared with me that his most vivid memory of shooting this episode
was how hot it was at Shrewt Farms,
and that you guys had to walk around in coats
pretending it was cold.
I noticed my forehead was glistening.
Yeah.
I'm not one to sweat, guys.
I'm not a big sweater because I'm always cold.
So if it tells you anything about how hot it was, I was sweating.
Also, real random side note,
sorry if this is an overshare,
when we were filming this, I had a five-month-old,
and I would have to go and pump.
You were pumping at Shrewd.
Farnes? I pumped at Shroup Farms. Where? They had like, first of all, our trailers were a little bit of a car right away. Yeah. And they just helped me get there because I would have to go pump. You pumped at Shrute Farms. I pumped at Shrute Farms in the heat. Wow. Things you do for your baby. Back at Dundermifflin, Pam is trying to get Michael on her side with the chairs, but she gets interrupted by Oscar who suddenly wants to go to lunch with Michael. Oh, Oscar knows exactly what he's doing. All Michael.
ever once is lunch with the guys and Jim's in on it.
Yeah.
Oh, this is a bold move.
Oh, yeah.
This is Michael's happiest day.
Pam says, it is on.
It is so on.
And then she puts on lipstick and she tossles her hair.
What?
What is the outcome of this just to, like, flirt with Michael and make him feel good?
I don't know what she is planning except maybe just.
to look at Michael with some happy eyes to pay attention to him laugh at his jokes.
But Jim, Michael, and Oscar get back from lunch, and they are hysterically laughing.
I mean, they've had the best time.
Yeah.
I mean, how is Pam going to compete with this?
She tries.
She goes into his office.
She compliments his pants.
She compliments his tie.
Hot tie guy.
And I love how excited Michael is to share that he got his tie for $4 and his pants for $9 at T.J. Max.
Oh, my gosh, that reminds me of my mom.
Does it?
Yes.
So my mom and my sister, they love to go to the outlets at Lake Ozark, Missouri.
All growing up, we would go to this cabin in Lake of the Ozarks in the summer, and they would head out to the outlets.
I'm not a shopper person.
I'm like, I'm going to stay back, I'm going to sit on the dock and read a book.
Oh, I would be hitting those outlets with them.
I know you would.
Especially if there was like one of those pretzel shops and I could get a pretzel while we shop.
Of course there's a pretzel shop.
Of course.
Give me that cinnamon pretzel.
Yes.
So you know how nowadays they have those hall videos where on YouTube where people go shopping and they just take things out of their bag and they show you their hall?
H-A-U-L.
Yeah.
I thought you said, you know those hall videos.
I'm like, why do they film themselves walking down a hall?
That's what I thought.
I thought, who does that?
Are they walking through the hall at the store?
No.
Like, hall.
Like, here's my hall.
Here's what I got.
Yes.
They would come home and they would get their stuff out of their bags.
Yeah.
And it was sort of like the hall videos because they would show every item.
But part of the showing of the item would have to include the price.
How much money they saved.
So the retail, I got this purse that retails for $44.
I got it for 12.
Yeah.
This shirt, this was 70% off at Ralph Lauren.
I got it for 12 bucks.
Yeah.
So the whole, like, description was always saying the price with the savings.
I think it was a big show for my dad, you know, so that he would feel better about any.
Well, your dad loves a deal.
He loves a deal.
This is what I know about him.
Oh, yeah.
He wouldn't want my mom to buy a $12 shirt unless she could get it for $7.
That's right.
You know?
So we would always have to make a big show of all the money that was saved.
Michael's right there with your family.
He sure is.
He could get in on it with my mom and my sister.
Pam really did lay it on thick.
There is a Michael talking head in the script right after all of this, right?
He's been taking a lunch.
Pam has just complimented him.
And it didn't make it in.
And Jenna, I loved it.
Here it is.
Michael's talking head in the script.
When people kiss up to you, it's very easy to get an inflated ego.
You can start to believe the hype that people are saying about you.
I'm not at that point yet, but I'm going to get there.
But I'm going to get there.
That's pretty amazing.
I know.
Back at Shrewd farms, they are inside the farmhouse, and Angela and Dwight are arguing over what kind of butter sculpture she should have at the wedding.
Lady, this scene was so much longer.
it actually started with Andy signing a ton of paperwork because he was actually signing as a witness to the wedding, but he didn't know.
Oh.
Dwight said it was all these insurance forms so that they could get married at Shrewp Farms.
And during this scene, Moes enters.
And there's a really awkward moment with Moes where Angela hises at him.
And then Dwight goes, why do you have to do that?
It's not necessary.
He loves you.
And then Andy's like, how does he love her?
How does he know her?
And then Dwight's like, oh, Moes loves everybody.
He's a people person.
And it's so much longer.
And then it ends with us arguing about the butter sculptures.
And once again, we could not get through it.
We were laughing so hard.
It's in the deleted scenes on the DVD.
I'm going to put it in stories, Jenna, because I had to cover my face.
I pull a Mindy.
You can see me laughing with my hands over my face.
But yes, then they get into this ridiculous argument about this sculpture.
and that's what made it in the actual episode.
We got a fan question from Gabriella T.
Who said, Angela tells Dwight she wants a cat sculpture made out of cow butter for her wedding.
I am from Iowa.
And every year at the Iowa State Fair, there is a cow butter sculpture on display.
The very first cow butter was sculpted in 1911, and it has grown to be a famous tradition at the Iowa State Fair.
Love it.
I did a deep dive on cow butter sculptures.
I want to hear it.
All right.
So at the Iowa State Fair, every year they make a life-size cow out of butter.
A whole cow?
Yeah.
That's huge.
It starts with a frame of wood, metal, wire, and steel mesh.
Okay.
And then they add 600 pounds of low moisture, pure cream, Iowa butter.
It sits in a 40-degree cooler, and then layers of butter are.
applied until it is full-sized. It measures five and a half feet high and eight feet long.
What? Yeah. I saw pictures. It's a cow, but it's butter. I need to see the picture.
I'll send it to you. So a real dairy cow weighs like a thousand pounds. The butter version
weighs about 600 pounds. Wow. This butter cow could butter about 19,200 pieces.
of toast. And this part I'm unsure about, but every year, most of the butter from the butter cow
is recycled and it can be used for up to 10 years. I hope so. That's a lot of butter. It is.
Would you not use the recycled cow sculpture butter? Well, I mean, they don't know. Five second
rule. Kind of. Not really. They also do a companion butter sculpture every year.
to the cow? The cow has a buddy? Yes. That stands next to it? Correct. What is it? Well, one year it was Elvis
Presley. What? A butter Elvis. Elvis? Made out of butter. Oh my gosh. Another year it was Harry Potter.
Oh, get out. Another year, they did Star Trek. And in 2018, they did a celebration of the 100th
anniversary of John Deere. Was there a tractor? Yes. Oh, my dad would have loved that. They did
a replica of the Waterloo boy tractor. I took a picture and it's a tractor out of butter next to the cow.
Wow. I wonder if you could climb up in it. Probably not. Well, I'm not eating that recycled butter.
Sorry to interrupt you guys. I got to catch, I caught one thing from the start of the podcast. Hold on real quick.
Oh, no. It's got to fix it. Okay. No, it's fine. Just give me one second. I can, I can repair it.
Okay.
Hold on.
Please.
All right, Angela. How do you feel? This is your first.
work birthday. You guys so got me. You so got me. I was so surprised. I really thought when I got here that
the guitar was code for cake. And then when it wasn't, I was like, oh, well, maybe they've just all been
busy and, oh, okay. I feel bad I went off on that rant. Well, what happened, Angela,
was that we were going to surprise you at the top of the podcast with a cookie-puss cake.
A Carvel cookie-puss cake? Yes. But there was a problem that happened.
and the cake got lost in transit.
Poor Cassie has been hiding out here since like 9.30 this morning waiting for this cake delivery.
Poor Cassie, by the way, this is the first time we've all been in person, and it's amazing to see you.
Cassie, say hi to everyone.
Hey, everybody.
Yay!
Well, I saw a few times you had to check your phone and text, but I thought it was all about the guitar.
No, it was a panic thread about your cake.
Oh, no.
And then you called us out, and we were like, no, but we had a cake and it's jimba.
And also, Cassie put together this amazing board for you.
It is all of these cards that people sent in because they heard that you did not get your birthday celebrated properly.
And so people from the office ladies' Facebook page sent you cards.
That is so sweet.
They know because I was real chatty that I never had a cake at work or at school.
You guys, that is so lovely.
Well, we could not let you start your 50s without a proper work birthday.
Thank you guys so much.
I love every single second.
I was truly surprised.
And I cannot wait to read all of these cards that you guys sent in.
It's so lovely.
I'm going to sit down and read every single one.
And thank you for my cake at Cake End.
It happened.
Oh, my gosh.
Well, before we did your birthday, we were talking about butter sculpture.
I know. It's really hard you guys. Now I'm like, okay, we got to work. We still have work to do. I know.
We were talking about cat butter sculptures.
And y'all, I googled cat butter sculptures.
And let me tell you, it does not disappoint.
Google image cat butter sculptures.
Can I tell you the very first one that came up?
Yeah.
I'm going to show it to you.
I'm going to put it in stories.
How do I describe this to you guys?
This is the first one that came up for me.
There's more than one.
It is a cat made out of butter, pooping butter pooping butter poop.
next to a block of butter.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, I guess it's a thing.
There was more than one by different people.
What's that about?
I don't know.
I have to think this is not the cat butter sculpture, Angela Martin would want.
There's also some majestic cats out there made of butter.
It was amazing.
People do really weird things with butter.
They do weird things with cats.
There's the whole litter box birthday cake.
Have you seen those?
Yes.
Where it's a cake and it looks like litter and then you make like tutsy.
rolls into poops?
Yeah.
For the cat lover in your life.
Put that next to the butter, cat pooping butter.
Happy birthday.
Next year.
That's it.
That's my cake next year.
I want the cat litter box cake.
All right.
There was also a deleted Andy talking head after the scene because this would have been
if you're keeping manure count, the second pile of manure he steps in.
Yes.
It's really funny.
You guys, he's outside by the barn, hosing off his show.
and he's sobbing and he says, this just isn't how I imagined it.
There's just so much shit.
It was really funny.
That is on the DVD.
Oh, back at the office, Jim is watching Pam struggle with the copier.
Everyone's really laying it on thick with Michael.
They're making him hot chocolate.
They're opening doors for him.
It's the best day of his life.
It really is.
We had a fan question from Stephanie M.
At 10 minutes, 25 seconds, Michael walks into his office and off camera, we hear him say, I almost choked.
Was that a line that was scripted?
Or did Steve Correll actually almost choke on his drink?
It was neither.
It was an improvisation.
He's doing that as Michael.
He was not choking.
He's going to choke later on some tiramisu powder.
It's the funniest choking scene I've ever seen.
Ever seen.
I want to study.
I want to study it.
I so believed it.
At first, I thought, was that scripted?
I had to go look.
I had to look, too.
It was so brilliant.
And then he did that thing, and we're jumping ahead, you guys.
But after two bites that were failed attempts, because he's choking, he goes for a third.
And then with his hands, he's like, no, no.
Yeah, he has to stop himself.
So good.
Dwight is going to take Angela to a new barn.
Mm-hmm.
It's beautiful.
It's gorgeous.
He's decorated it, like, how.
it will be on her wedding day with chairs and sparkly lights. Yeah. And Andy's like,
Hey, because he's happy too. Yeah, there's a priest. And no manure. It's perfect.
Dwight is going to suggest that they sort of roleplayed the ceremony. He wants Andy to get a bird's
eye view. So he says, you know, you walk her down as if you're her father and she'll marry me.
But, you know, so you can see what it looks like. Yes. And, you know, the priest doesn't speak any English.
He only speaks German, so they don't know what he's saying.
In the script, it says Angela Martin is moved to tears by this moment.
I think because it is really playing out what's in her true heart, which would be what it would be like to marry Dwight.
Yeah.
We had a fan question from L.E.B.
In the scene where Dwight and Angela are getting married at Shreve Farms, is the minister actually speaking German?
Yes.
All of the German in this scene is accurate.
the actor who played the priest was posth boyd, and he was cast because he was fluent in German.
Mm-hmm.
And also because he was comfortable riding horses.
Yes, because he rides a horse at the end.
Randy said that the actor arrived early to set that day so that he could select one of the horses and practice on it.
Mm-hmm.
Randy also said that they had to submit a translated version of the priest's script to the NBC legal department of standards and practices.
because we had to prove that we weren't trying to sneak in any dialogue that would be considered unacceptable to the censors.
It feels like they didn't trust us.
I wonder why.
Well, here is the translation.
The priest is saying,
Groom and bride,
you come here voluntarily with hearts prepared to receive each other in marriage?
Will you love each other,
respect, and be loyal to one another until death separates you?
Are you ready to fulfill?
your obligation to raise your children as Christian parents should. So that is what Dwight and
Angela are agreeing to in their marriage vows. I guess Dwight is going to forego standing in his own
grave to marry her just so he can make it happen. Yes, because that is truly the shrewd tradition.
And would tip off Andy. This whole thing is going to lead into Angela getting pretty sentimental.
Yeah, and she realizes I made a mistake with Andy.
She says she made a mistake.
I know.
She tells Dwight.
I picked the wrong guy.
Dwight, man, he just messed it up.
He does because he gets real arrogant.
He's like, I know, and I took care of it.
I fixed it.
And he sneakily had them married without her consent.
And she does not like that and does not appreciate it.
No.
He almost had her back in that moment.
Yep.
But no.
No.
She's furious with him that he was.
would do such a huge life moment in this sneaky way. We got a fan question from Rebecca M.
Does Dwight's secret marriage actually count in the state of Pennsylvania? Or did the writers make
this up? Good question. Well, Pennsylvania is actually one of the only states where you can do something
called self-unite. So Colorado also allows this. According to the American Civil Liberties Union
of Pennsylvania, the tradition of self-uniting in marriage dates back to 1681. It has its roots in the
state's Quaker population. And because the religious sect does not have any ministers,
members of the Quaker faith traditionally self-unite in marriage. So these are often referred to as
Quaker licenses, but self-uniting licenses do not require the applicants to practice any specific
religion or any religion at all. So under Pennsylvania marriage law, couples wishing to marry without
an officiant can obtain a self-uniting license. They can perform their own ceremony. The only rule is
there have to be at least two witnesses who are required to sign the document. Which Angela and Andy
signed this insurance document and I guess the priest would have signed something. Yes. In this scenario,
the priest and Andy were the witnesses.
So, this marriage was legal.
How about that?
This would have led to a delicious, deleted car ride home scene.
Lady, it's a rough one.
It's right up there with a Jan Michael car ride home.
All right?
This was in the shooting script.
It's not on the DVD.
It's out there somewhere in the world, you guys.
It was so amazing.
Angela is driving home, furious.
Dwight's in the front passenger seat.
Andy is in the back, leaning between the two of them.
And they start out the car ride, and Andy's like, we did it!
He's so happy, and he starts singing at the top of his lungs, this song.
That's what he's singing in the back seat.
That exact part of the song is in the script.
What you just heard is four non-blonds.
And Angela is so annoyed that Andy is singing, so she turns off the
radio and Andy keeps singing and comes in with this part. That sounds like Andy to me. Right? Yeah. In the script,
it says Angela looks like she might drive the car into a tree. Dwight is stealing glances at Angela.
Andy, oblivious, is singing for nonblots. Wow. How did you get through that with Ed singing in the
back seat, though? How did you keep a straight face? I'm telling you, we laughed through this whole episode.
Every single thing was funny to me. This next scene is the one that I could not.
get through. I don't know how you did. It's one of my favorite scenes of the whole episode. It's one of my
favorite scenes of the whole series. Yes, it's my favorite Hank scene. Oh, yeah. So Michael, who can't
make a decision, has decided to call Hank from security. Yeah. Who, as he explains, hustled up the
stairs because he thought it was an actual emergency. Well, you know, Michael texts people 911 to get their
retention. So Hank arrives, and I just want to say this was one of those scenes that was set at the
reception desk, and I'm in the shot, and I wanted to edge myself out of the shot because I was
ruining it because I was laughing. From the minute Hugh walks in, the minute he takes a few of the
candies and starts eating them, I was like, I wouldn't make it. That was an improvisation,
and the first time he did it, I laughed. Because it was so brilliant. It's so,
Brilliant.
So Michael is going to ask Hank, what do we do?
He makes a big announcement.
He's like, listen, Hank is going to decide.
Yeah.
And Hank's like, can I see the copier?
Opens up doors and stuff, looks at it.
And he's like, now let me see the chair.
And the room is riveted.
They're hanging on his every word.
But the scene ends amazing.
My favorite is the ending of the scene.
My favorite.
Well, first of all, he's sort of like.
He, like, explains his theory why the office would need both.
There's new copiers.
They're amazing.
Yeah.
Although those chairs, he could not sit in.
Yes.
And Michael's like, so?
And everyone's waiting.
And he goes, let me look at the cop here again.
Michael's like, get out.
Get out.
It's so funny.
Angela, this was the first time for office ladies that I have watched the show with my kids.
Oh, really?
Yes.
Oh, I watch them all the time with my kids.
I know.
I know, I know.
It was a pinch, and I said, guys, I have to watch this.
I have to watch it.
You can watch it with me or you can go outside and scooter or something.
So I turned it on.
First of all, my son was just giggling through the whole thing.
He's a little older, so I think he got more of the humor.
The humor, yeah.
But this moment when he says, let me see the copier again.
And Michael said, get out.
They were dying.
And then they started doing it as a bit.
That is so good.
It was so fun.
Gosh, I'm so excited as my kids get older for them to discover it.
Yeah.
I know.
Well, my kids love The Office, and, you know, every once in a while we'll watch an episode, and Isabel will go, Mom, because Angel Martin is so mean.
And you know, Jack, my stepson loves Office Ladies.
I know.
Whenever I see him, he'll tell me some fun thing he heard on Office Ladies, which I love.
He was like, I'm so excited that you guys are going to talk to Stephen Merchant.
I love that they watched it with you.
So we kind of already talked about this scene where Michael is eating tiramisu while talking to David Wallace.
But what we did not mention is that David gives him some new information.
Yeah.
He's like any boss that comes in under budget gets 15% of that surplus.
Michael whips out his calculator and he discovers that means he could get $645.
Do you know how far that can go at Burlington?
Ten Co Factory? You're literally a king if you walk in there with $645. Well, Michael's got dollar
signs now on the brain. Michael walks out of his office and he announces that he doesn't think
they need a new copier or new chairs. He demonstrates that the copier works perfectly and then he's
going to demonstrate how great Pam's chair really is. Two things. First of all, in the bloopers,
Jenna, when Steve tries to use the copier, that copier actually...
actually was really crappy. It was awful. It was really old and crappy and half the time would not work
in real life. When we needed it to. When we needed it to. And it would eat paper. It would like make
noises. And he says, this copier works fine. And he hits the button. And in real life, it went,
and you guys all started laughing. It was so funny. Paul Fieg sent us an audio clip because this was
one of his favorite memories from shooting this episode. Here's what he had to say. There was so many
fun things in season five, but weirdly, one of my favorite episodes that we did was the surplus.
And it's an episode that people don't talk about as much. And I just think it's got some of the
funniest stuff in it. I think I laughed harder during that. My favorite gag, one of my favorite
gags that I ever got to do on the office was when Michael's trying to convince everybody that they
don't need a new copier and all the chairs are good. And we had that gag, Jenna, where he comes
behind the desk and just tries to prove that your chair is not broken. And I had them rig up this thing,
because the whole joke is supposed to be he sits on your chair and it just sinks down below the desk.
And so worked really hard to have them rig this chair up that sunk so slowly that Steve just got in it
and is just talking like, see, there's nothing wrong of this. And it takes you a few seconds to realize
that he's just very slowly sinking down behind the desk. And then just Steve just destroyed me when,
And not only is he down low, but he won't admit it.
And then the way he has to stand up is like, hey, it takes such effort for him to get
out of the very low chair.
So that was a real favorite gag of mine.
Well, every time he would get out of the chair, he would make some other different grunting
noise, and it would do me in.
If you watch my face in the scene, I have this really, like, over-exaggerated, furrowed
brow. I was having to make a very strong acting choice because I couldn't do blank. I couldn't do it.
I had to do something with my face. Right. I had completely forgotten about this scene and when I
rewatched it, because it's been a long time since I've seen this episode. And when I rewatched it
this week, I was like watching it and I was like, wait, is this chair sinking? Oh my God,
it's chair sinking. And it was so funny. It was so funny and it's so subtle. It's such a small moment.
And in order to make it work, I could not be sitting on the chair at the beginning of the scene.
So it looks like I'm sitting and then he comes over and takes my seat.
I had to squat.
Thigh workout.
And hold my butt and hover.
And you can tell a little bit, because in order to do it, I kind of had to like, you know, really like spread my legs to get like a good solid squat on the chair, above the chair.
Yeah.
It's like going to the bathroom in a porta potty.
Yes.
Halfway through your pee, like your legs start shaking.
You're like, oh, crap, I need to work out more.
This was a workout day for me.
Oh, my gosh.
That's how we pulled off that gag.
Also, in this moment, everyone starts to realize that Michael knows about the bonus.
Oscar calls him out.
He's like, I think you know.
And he's like, what's 15% of 4,300?
That's the surplus.
And Michael immediately goes $645.
And he's like, why did you say dollars?
And he's like, that's just how my brain.
works.
Yeah.
And Kevin goes, he's a genius.
Then Oscar says, okay, Michael, what's 15% of 200?
And then Michael doesn't know.
That little bit of Kevin thinking that Michael is a math genius in that moment,
Paul Feak said him and his wife, Lori, love that little bit and that they do that bit.
That like, if someone says something, they'll be like, he's a genius.
Oh, they do Kevin.
That's their little bit.
all of this leads to a very big smooch.
Andy and Dwight and Angela have returned to the office.
Yeah.
And once you piss Angela off, she's going to dig in her heels.
And she's going to make a very public show to Dwight that she has chosen once again
Andy over him.
Yeah.
So Andy is eating a tuna sandwich that he's real proud of.
He wants Jim to know, tuna, I'm eating tuna.
And Angela marches across the book.
Bullpin and kisses him.
Mm-hmm.
He's leaning back in his chair.
She lays on his lap and grabs his face.
Do you know what the stage direction was for this kiss?
Read it.
Angela kisses Andy with a passion we haven't seen since Jim and Pam in Casino Night.
I know.
I read that.
We had a lot of questions about this scene, though, Angela.
Oh, well, I bet I have some stories for you.
Dory C and Amanda C both want to know.
Did Ed actually have tuna in his mouth when you kissed him?
Yes.
Oh!
That was part of the joke.
Lee and Gene, who wrote this episode, they thought it would be very funny if Andy was eating something gross when I had to go kiss him.
And that's why he has that line, look, tuna, tuna fish sandwich, just like you.
Because they really wanted to make sure the audience knew he was eating this smelly tuna fish sandwich.
And I was supposed to go over and we're supposed to have this huge kiss.
while he has tuna fish in his mouth.
And then you see me get up and I wipe my mouth.
Yeah.
Ed was so sweet.
He said, Angela, I am going to hold my lips together.
I'm going to take a deep breath.
I'm going to take a bite of the tuna fish sandwich.
And then I am going to purse my lips together and not open them at all because I don't want you to get any of this tuna fish.
I was like, oh, Ed, that is so sweet.
And so we literally did, you know, what we call like grandparent kissing where you're just like,
he did not open his lips for a second. And they really wanted me to sort of have this long kiss, right?
Yeah. And I was in control. I was the one that grabbed him and then I was the one that released him.
And I remember one time they were like, can you sell it a little bit more? Can you make it a little bit bigger of a moment?
And poor Ed, the minute we broke apart, he went, because he hadn't been breathing?
He was holding his breath with a big bite of tuna for sandwich in his mouth.
Here's my question. Couldn't Phil have made faky tuna fish? I don't know. Would that have been better?
I don't know. I mean, what could it have been? I don't know. You could have maybe, I mean, whatever it is, it's going to be mayo based. But it could have been chopped up chicken. I would have bought it. But it's not as stinky. It's true. But Ed was a true gentleman. He kept his mouth closed. I didn't get any tuna fish on my person. And you guys, when my character's
stands up and says, and now I have a legal issue to attend to, I actually had a big speech that got
deleted.
Really?
Yes.
And I was so nervous to do it because it was one of those moments where I had a speech in the
bullpen with everyone looking at me.
This is how the script described everyone reacting to the kiss and my speech after.
Okay.
Everyone watches with disgust.
Dwight's eyes go wide.
Angela pulls away.
Andy continues to chew and then swallows the bite.
Angela wipes her mouth and here's the speech.
I would marry you during an earthquake in the middle of a tornado.
I would marry you in the front row of an Elton John concert.
I don't care how terrible a place it is.
I just want to be with you.
Now, I have a legal matter to clear up.
Not an Elton John fan.
Clearly.
Clearly not.
But yeah, so I had that speech I had to do.
And they gave me a few alts, you know.
I was really nervous, but all that made it in was now I have a legal matter to clear up.
And I actually think that was a good edit because the kiss was enough.
Yeah.
Right?
That was enough of like shoving it in Dwight's face.
I didn't need to make this speech.
But yes, no tuna.
Thank you, Ed.
Very different from a kiss with Rain who would.
Actually was eating tuna in real life.
Backstage for no reason at all.
Knowing he has.
Yes.
that are drinking coffee while eating like an everything bagel that had onions on it.
Yeah.
Different.
Very different.
Approaches.
This whole copier chair thing is going to wrap up.
The employees are going to confront Michael in his office.
And he basically tells them, you know what?
You decide.
You all have to agree or else I'm taking the bonus.
Because he kind of thinks like there's no way that's going to happen, right?
Of course.
he thinks there's no way. He thinks he got him. They very quickly decide to get the chairs.
He was like, son of a. He actually says mother. Yeah, he does. F. Was he putting sugar in his
Diet Coke? He was. Yeah, he wanted to sweeten it. Oh, my Lord. The whole thing kind of ends with
Michael. He has a talking head. He wants you to know what he learned. What did he learn? He learned that
his team is faster at making a decision than he thought. He always, he always, he always, he always,
He also learned you should never buy a fur coat with a credit card until you actually have the money to pay for it.
Michael, why in the world are you buying a fur coat? You're never going to wear it.
It's ridiculous looking.
Yes. He's just like a kid that gets money and doesn't know what to do with it.
In his mind, that's, I don't know, fancy luxury or something.
Yeah, fancy people have those or something.
I guess so. The third thing he learned is that people think it's cool to throw fake blood on you as you leave Burlington Coat Factory.
So he has a ruined fur coat that he bought on credit.
That he can't afford.
Yeah.
That's how his day ended.
Jim and Pam's day is going to end with a truce.
But oh, can you make me three copies of this?
I'm just kidding.
I need four.
Is this Jim Sass?
Oh, that's some Jim Sass.
I have one final question for you.
Yes.
Would you be team copier or team chair?
Team chair.
What would you be?
Team chair. Yeah, team copier doesn't even make any sense to me, frankly. I mean, I would just suffer
through a crappy machine. How many times have you worked in an office where either the fax machine?
I know I'm a dinosaur or the copier didn't work great. But a chair, that's like your tailbone. That's
your spine. That's your butt. Is anyone team copier? Can we put a poll in Office Ladies Pod today?
Yes. I'm so curious. I'll put a poll and we'll see. We want to see. Well, you guys, that was
spend the surplus.
And also Angela's birthday.
Hey!
Whoop, whoo!
Yay!
Angela!
Next time I talk to you guys,
I'll be American surveyed, 50 to 75.
That'll be me.
See you next week.
Bye.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink.
This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by
Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle.
Our second drinks episodes are produced
by Molly Nugent. Our audio engineer
is Sam Pfeiffer. Odyssey's
executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered
by Bill Schultz. Our theme song
is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton.
Hey y'all. It's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair.
Ever order furniture online and wonder
what if? Like, what if it doesn't hold up?
That sofa was four days old.
You should have ordered from Wayfair. With Wayfair, there's no what if.
Just style you love and quality you can trust.
Visit wayfair.ca.
Wayfair, every style, every home.